with a lot of presentations I always
prepare in advance and and try to get
everything in the presentation in my
brain so I've got it there and I can
just have a natural sort of comfortable
presentation and then along comes sugar
daddy calm and you know all my
preparation just sort of goes out the
window but we'll we'll try to suffer
through it actually in my talk you're
going to get a twofer it's it's actually
two presentations in 1 i'm going to talk
about data as code and then turn that
around and talk about code as data now
what we're specifically talking about
here is we back up a definition I'll
take a definition of each one so if you
talk about code as data that's taking a
very large batch of code a large
application with thousands or millions
of lines associated with it and treating
that in and of itself as data you know
we all work with data right but we work
with things like customer records or
orders in a supply chain we don't
normally think about code itself as
being data but when we do that we can
find some very interesting things that
come as a result of that the second part
of that is data now as code so think of
a bunch of code fragments thousands
millions of code fragments that are in
some kind of searchable repository that
can then be recalled and executed that
also presents sort of some interesting
ramifications as well so let me let me
walk through this and see what it what
it might mean so let me take the first
part of that which is code as data that
is a large code base yes ah yes
certainly can do that
150 is that is that good enough for
everybody you'll see that great okay so
when you think about code when you
attack code and you just look at it and
hit just here this is a snippet of some
code that we wrote recently in a in a
forecasting model you can say all right
well I'm gonna I'm going to break all
this code up into everything that's
between some kind of delimiter in the
Wolfram language it's it's a semicolon
but it does lend itself it does lend
itself to the decomposition by by some
structure the structure that then we
could attack now the reason we were sort
of inspired to think about code as data
was an actual project that we were doing
for a financial services firm this
financial services firm had purchased
another similar financial services firm
their code base had been written outside
of the United States it was millions of
lines of code and they were concerned
about okay what am I getting what am i
buying and I are their vulnerabilities
in this this code that we that we
inherited by virtue of this merger so
part of our assignment was to then take
a look at that that code and the
features of this code to see what we
could find so here hence the question so
what do you get when you when you do
this when you treat code is data so some
of the things that we look for and I'll
blow this up so you can see this as well
as certain patterns so one of the first
things that we did was we said all right
well there there is a graph it's not
scrolling for me there's a graph of the
data this way so this is all the
functions are represented as nodes and
if they call another function that's
represented as an edge associated with
the two nodes so you can you can use
this to look at certain redundancies you
can look at it was sort of almost like a
lean a lean thinking kind of idea where
you want your code to be as efficient as
possible but if there are all of these
kinds of connections they present a
pattern that might suggest some code in
efficiencies there's also the idea of
bottlenecks so same ever on that I can
open up some code that where we were
looking at some of these bottlenecks I
had to take a couple of things out of
this but we did look at how many
user-defined functions there were as
opposed to built-in functions so this is
and you're not going to be able to read
this and doesn't matter that you can
read this but we took a batch of code
and we we highlighted in blue the
user-defined functions and in red these
were the Wolfram language functions and
certain bunches of wolf strings of
Wolfram language functions had
implications certain bunches of patterns
in user-defined functions also had
implications as to the structure of this
code so we could ravit we could use the
Wolfram language with all of its power
and capability to visualize you know any
kind of scientific phenomena we could
train that same power onto code there
was another aspect and I I will go into
the technical details here I'm happy to
answer questions but we were sort of
looking at nesting there was a sort of a
nesting structure that was in place
since we were able to to visualize that
with with a 2d graph and then break all
of that down so it was it was quite
illuminating to look at this code and to
then report back to the company that
hired us that look we found this these
patterns in the code we found this
evidence of malicious elements or
inefficient elements in the code but you
know it got us thinking after that
project about you know well it's broaden
our definition of what code is let's
think about contracts illegal contracts
I mean that essentially is
much the work that you do in breaking
down code is similar to the work that
you might do in breaking down a legal
contract and making it computable so we
along comes a company that is in the
oilfield service business so let me let
me tell you this story they came to us
and they said look we we drill oil wells
for a living and we want to know how
much money we're making day by day
literally hour by hour and we said okay
well why is that a big deal that should
be easy well it's not a big deal when
they showed me the contract between the
oilfield service company and their
client who was the national oil company
this happened to be Pemex the the
contract was about that thick and it was
written by lawyers so it's not
necessarily written to be computable so
we did a lot of manual tedious work to
take a legal contract and then decompose
it into computable rules but the same
kinds of techniques that you use to
break down code in that previous example
you could also use to break down
legal-contracts here's another sort of
interesting thing that we found when we
were doing this work is that it really
doesn't take a whole lot of modification
to a legal contract to make it
computable so you know for attorneys out
there you are very close actually to
having something that that is computable
so we finally were able to take the
contracts and and the reason this is
complicated is because this firm they're
cut their clauses in how they make
revenue out of drilling and oil well is
you get up you get a little bonus if you
maintain a certain pressure you get a
little bonus if you drill so many feet
per day and all of these exotic sort of
rules and clauses we had to make
computable in order to compute the real
time revenue so when we finally did that
it looks something like this so now
you've got a drill
a bit going down into the earth and then
it goes down so far and then it comes
back out and it goes back down again and
it comes back out but you can see on
that right-hand side of the display
we're showing how much we are making the
green line how much we're spending the
red line so we were able to do something
that they previously had not been able
to do which is juxtaposed the financial
information against the operational
information in real time think of it as
a profit loss statement at the drill bit
and the enabling methodology the
enabling technology that made that
happen was to take code contract and
turn it into something computable so you
know we were really excited when we were
able to sort of finally do this because
if you sort of broaden your definition
of what is data it makes these kinds of
applications possible okay so it's going
to go through so the 39 days of drilling
I used to always think that when you
drilled a well it was like sort of Jed
Clampett you know firing the gun and the
oil just sort of spurts out of the
ground it's not they said George that's
not exactly how it works you you drill a
certain amount then you come out and
drill back in again so it's a it's for
this it was a very complex set of
processes took place over 39 days but
interestingly that that whole idea came
about because we were able to apply the
sort of code as data notion and the the
other thing that I'm seeing and maybe
you're seeing as well is the emergence
of these graph databases and ontologies
so instead of treating data as just sort
of structured data in some Cartesian
kind of data set but actually building
an ontology building dr. Wolfram
mentioned this earlier you know building
at sort of an ontology of here are the
objects in my world and here's what
attributes they have and here's what
what they're capable of doing I think
this data as code excuse me this code as
data idea has the potential to allow us
to automatically
build ontology and that's I think is the
Holy Grail in this whole equation is if
we can automate these currently tedious
human processes of taking a body of
knowledge and making it computable I
mean right now it's it it is very
manually intensive and I think that's
holding back a lot of the applications
of this from being economically feasible
because they're not automated but the
emergence of ontologies allows us then
to perhaps grab a of information that
just exists in its natural form and
putting that into a federated kind of
database all right so that's enough
about the the code as data idea let's
look at data as code now skipping around
all right so the the central idea behind
e data as code is thinking about code
existing in a database itself when we
think about code we think of these big
sort of monolithic systems with with
millions of lines of code and that's
that's in fact the most common state
that this code exists in but what if you
had code fragments would that were
actually in data what if you could
recall those code fragments and build
them run them on the fly you know what
would that do I mean certainly one of
the things that we can think about that
and this was a this was a real
application a sort of application
concept that that somebody proposed to
me which is you know think about your
car there's a lot of software in your
car right now and you use your car in
all different kinds of places sometimes
the weather is this sometimes the
location is that so so the car really
should react its its traction system its
braking system it really should react to
all those kinds of conditions so you've
got sort of a couple of choices here as
a designer of the system one is you
could build this just huge
out of code that accounts for every
possible of weather condition location
altitude or you could actually keep a
lot of that code in a searchable sort of
database so essentially the car pulls
its code together compiles it and runs
it as as it's going and a very real
application of that is some work that we
recently did where we were working with
a chemical plant and the chemical plant
had yield equations for the chemical
processes they were making nylon so this
is stuff that starts with you know
things like ammonia and crude oil and
sort of puts them together reacts them
in certain ways over lots and lots and
lots of steps and ultimately produces
this nylon product well those yields
very you know much like the car example
those yields vary by temperature and
time of day and the quality of the raw
material is this huge number of
variations so again we could have chosen
to put a big sort of switch statements
at the very top of our code if all of
these conditions are present then do
this otherwise if these conditions are
present then do this it was much easier
from a design standpoint to put all of
those little code fragments those those
yield equations into a database and
you're seeing just sort of a spreadsheet
of some of these equations coming up and
it had this sort of the handy byproduct
of allowing the company also to change
those equations outside of the core code
which is an important i think capability
so I've been kind of watching
applications in this space and one of
the interesting applications that you
you may have seen is called viv so the
original sort of Siri team reconstituted
themselves over to this company called
viv and they gave an interview in Wired
magazine last year and they talked about
viv and is essentially this intelligence
agent not unlike Siri that responds to
certain requests so they say you know I
won't read the whole quote here but he
says viv breaks through the constraints
of coding and programming by generating
its own code on the flight now I I don't
know anything about the internal
architecture of viv but what I'm
noticing in the work that I do in kind
of the research that I'm trying to do in
thinking about this is that I'm seeing
statements like this out in the media a
lot more frequently this notion of sort
of coding on the fly so what viv does is
it processes a statement like on my way
to my brother's house I need to pick up
some cheap wine that goes well with
lasagna and then they go on to kind of
break they show you how viv actually
sort of breaks all of this down and it's
it's a it's it's a fascinating little
application I think that's that's less
important than the central idea here
which is that we have the ability to
then start putting these systems
together that actually program
themselves if you will because they have
at their disposal some database of code
fragments that they bring in only as
needed and then last but not least I'll
sort of conclude on this this situation
which is IFTTT now I'd like a raise of
hands how many of you ever heard of
ifttt or if okay great so many of you
have that's that's good if you haven't
heard about it you need to because I
think this is really a extraordinary
kind of capability if stands for if this
then that and it's a it's an application
framework that allows you to take apps
and essentially build strips around
these apps so some people have for
example said you know every time I take
a photo of my pet Ralph then I want you
to take that photo and post it
automatically on facebook or every time
my wife goes to the grocery store I want
to get an email message that she's at
the
grocery store or people who are even
starting to outfit their cars with these
little devices that fit into the
diagnostic port that then say if my car
and I'm terrible at this I can never
remember when to rotate the tires in my
car so I come to the tire dealer and
they say oh your tires are shredded so
I'd like to get one of these devices and
have it tell me if my car is ready to be
the tires already to be rotated send me
some kind of message that notifies me so
you can essentially put together any
range of absence supports like 150 apps
out there that you can use to trigger
some of these common actions it's like I
say it's extremely important sort of
category of application that we haven't
thought of up to now and here's the even
better news that Wolfram research thank
you very much well from research has now
built a channel as as if calls it of
Wolfram data drop so now you can have a
data drop out there thats collecting
information from you know any device you
want you know go go to the connected
devices list and you'll see all those
devices so in theory any of those
devices might qualify from for
connecting to a data drop that then you
can have it trigger some other kind of
action so that's for a lot of consumer
applications but think of the industrial
applications of something like
connecting if this then that sort of
capability to things had that happen
inside of of corporations I think that a
lot more to come this was just released
last week I'm not sure exactly which day
it was released on but there have been a
couple of posts where people have have
built applications based on Wolfram data
drop one of the applications was a
gentleman who put together an app that
showed his elevation so he had his phone
track his elevation is who sort of
hiking in a certain area and he later
looked at a lisp lot of all of the
elevations that he had been throughout
the day so that the you know the mind
just kind of race
is for applications you know that you
can do with with some of this okay so
essentially my my message to you is
really the singular message that you
know k if we sort of broaden our
thoughts on what constitutes data if we
broaden our thoughts on what constitutes
code lots and lots of applications are
unlocked and you know sometimes when we
got get caught up in a sort of everyday
world of working with this same sort of
or similar Cartesian data sets over and
over again it we need to sort of take
time and step back and say you know if
we if we sort of change our definitions
of what comprises those things it's sort
of unlocks are thinking in how we
approach data and in the shameless plug
department I've written a book sort of
on the subject about you know sort of
solving problems and how you might solve
problems using data using scientific
methods and that's that's just to be
released but there's a chapter on data
where I expand on a lot of these ideas
and so with that I'll conclude and I'll
take whatever questions you might have